[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thank you for
listening to this podcast there's so
many podcasts I talk about this all the
time I mean there's just podcast after
podcast but I've been here a lot longer
than most these podcasts Ryan admit it I
understand I started out I mean there
was nobody listening and not that
there's tons of people I mean it's good
listening it's a good following it's
good the year of Our Lord 2018. it was
quite a while ago but um you know
um I think during covet all of a sudden
everybody started a podcast look at all
this podcast right and the fact that you
guys still are listening to me
is awesome because I have a job and
Ryan's job Bryce's job and Jason his job
and I enjoy doing it and I feel like I'm
getting better at it I really do I feel
like I'm more comfortable than I've ever
been well but if you got 10 000 hours
yet
no I guess you have however many hours a
pilot Ryan
um but I've interviewed probably 250
people
yeah 250 interviews in the podcast plus
we did some repeats yeah some repeats
but still it was still an interview
um anyway I'm not I'm just saying thank
you for listening our handles are at
inside of you podcast on Instagram and
Facebook at inside epod it certainly
helps when you follow us and more
importantly it's important to write a
review if you like the podcast it makes
us jump up in the charts that's what
reviews do helps the podcast and you can
watch on YouTube
um I think we've got 200 000 subscribers
cool on inside of you and the clips
channel has over a hundred and something
thousand and uh it's exciting it's cool
it's like I I didn't think it would even
get to this place and so thanks Westwood
One thanks Ryan Bryce um
Jason
and my guests my guests who keep coming
uh we have a great guest today by the
way we'll be in Dallas this coming
Saturday and Sunday citing autographs
Tom Welling and I um at the creation con
with Jensen Ackles and Jared Padalecki
from Supernatural
um I might get up and sing loud and
Swain's playing
um
Saturday night we have a Smallville
nights event me and Tom reading scripts
prizes you don't want to miss it trust
me uh we've been doing it a lot now
probably 30 times and we haven't had one
person ever not like it it's always
everybody is so happy and have so much
fun and if they don't then I wouldn't be
doing it so get tickets to the event you
can go on my Twitter uh at Michael
Rosenbaum I was locked out
yeah that was a whole Saga it was and I
you know what's funny is I was like oh
[__] I need it back because you know
yeah a lot of people know what you know
your podcast is doing and you know and
and your work and life and and then uh I
finally just kind of gave up and I go
yeah I'm just done with Twitter I just I
got a new account whatever doesn't have
as many obviously as many followers and
um and then uh this girl Julie McNiven
an actress a great actress and she texts
me and says hey old friend I saw that
you were hacked um
I know somebody I go okay
and then that somebody called me or text
me and then I text them and they got in
touch with somebody and the next thing I
know within
48 Hours it was it was done Megan
Megan Hubble Megan Hubble really helped
me Megan you rock so I got the uh it's a
pain in the ass when things get hacked
because they're going we need your email
to verify go well they obviously took it
when I
hit the link so they changed the email
so I don't I would there was it was this
state of looping I was in a loop is that
we call it yeah it was uh it was anyway
it was inconvenient definition of
insanity yes yes that's exactly what it
is
um but anyway Dallas uh also if you want
to go the inside of you online store
we've got great stuff I've got the the
new ship Keys autographed and you know
uh Clark's ship that Lex takes the key
in so uh Smallville scripts leximus we
have those those are a big hit and a
bunch of other stuff uh figures and and
inside of you mugs and tumblers and all
that stuff so if you want to go there
and also of course the album sunspin.com
you can get our new album just came out
two weeks ago we uh we're everywhere
um Spotify Apple but if you want to buy
this CD I think it's an iTunes or you
can get the CD on sunspin.com along with
a cool merch we had a real successful
stage at show
and we performed virtually live it was
pretty awesome and so thanks for all
your support doing that and obviously
the talk fill podcast is is doing all
right and we have a good time doing that
so thanks for supporting that
um and that really about does it
um thank you so much and Zach Levi is
here
this is a good one I got him a cry I
didn't I don't want to say I got him a
cry I just we we got really deep I mean
this was you're gonna love this
conversation Jason was here you weren't
here for this interview I was not and
Jason was I really think like wow
Zach is really a really bright guy and
he there's something that's said here
that you'll when you guys watch or
listen that really affected me I forgot
I was being interviewed or interviewing
someone and it just made perfect sense
was about family and stuff like that so
listen it's a great interview I love it
he's got the new Shazam coming out he's
got so many other things coming out um
he's got his book
um radical love that you gotta check out
um he also has the audiobook for that so
you can hear his voice while you're
listening and uh I love him I love him
he's a really great friend of mine and
I'm glad to have him on the podcast so
let's get inside of Zach Levi it's my
point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
do you ever see you're Dawning already
you're yawning I'm trying to actually
pop my ears are you but I'm also but I
also have a little Yanni In Me yeah and
not the cello playing one did you listen
to Yanni no I never even I mean I'm sure
I've heard Yanni played on like no some
Mall rate you know of music or like in a
music in an elevator but I've never like
gone out of my way to listen to Yanni
which is not to say the man is not
talented could you could you could you
pin out or pick out uh if you're
listening to music in an elevator in a
mall and you heard Kenny G uh could you
uh could you oh that's Kenny G for sure
I think there are probably one or two
tracks tracks 22 songs that
would spark some kind of uh like you
know because like you know not too long
ago well I don't know actually decades
now that we think about it
um but you know there were commercials
for Kenny G and like you know so you
would hear them you would hear the
various you know songs that he would
play but without lyrics it's very
difficult like other than like Claire de
Lune or whatever like it's very
difficult for me to like listen to a
non-uh vocalized song and be like oh I
know that song you know I know that
track right I'm trying to uh find some
Kenny G yeah of course uh and I think
this is the Tale As Old As Time isn't
this the one that everybody knows
um
I love that Indiana Jones figurine
so good you like that yeah well it's
just really well done I mean like all
the little details and the craftsmanship
and it actually genuinely looks like
Harrison Ford's face as opposed to a lot
of other figurines that's true that just
you know they they they they with with
faces often times you know I mean it's
like sometimes they get it right
no this is not Kenny Kennedy doesn't
talk
hang on hang on sure that one but didn't
he but that's not the one I'm thinking
of that's like
there now that's Mash
no no that's mashed
I'm an idiot
yeah anyway you and I were talking about
uh we were talking about what were we
talking about well before conventions
yeah right well we're talking about
conventions before this and you were
talking about how when you started doing
conventions signing autographs and stuff
you're doing Chuck and you felt like you
went there and it was fine and the bands
are great and blah blah you went
somewhere in England bringing in England
yeah
don't you ever ever and and ultimately
you were like you know I'm gonna wait
till I I've done more well yeah look
ultimately yes prior to doing Chuck I
had only really done like one thing
which was this show less than perfect
which was a multi-camera sitcom that I
did on ABC that's actually when you and
I well no I met you I mean dang I met
you when I was like 19 or something you
don't even remember but it was a it was
bowling you used to do bowling on Like
Mondays or Tuesdays over in Studio City
yeah at pins with Tom Lennon and were
you with that group tomorrow Michael Ian
Black and uh I knew remember Ali Hillis
no no
I'm pretty sure that was her name um but
I met I met some people like coming down
and auditioning I didn't even live in LA
at the time I still lived in Ventura
with my parents but I would come down
and I you know in all the auditions and
stuff you'd meet people friends whatever
and uh and this girl Ali was like yeah
you should come I go to this bowling
night at pins and this guy you know
Michael Rosenbaum and all that stuff and
I and I knew who you were from the work
that you had already done which wasn't a
lot no but I mean you were a working
actor Jack and Jane and you know all the
things whatever
um and uh so anyway yeah so but but then
right after around and then when I was
21 I booked less than perfect
and so from 2002 to 2005 I did this
sitcom but you know sitcoms that's not a
convention work I mean actually nowadays
it's like almost anything can go to a
convention it's really kind of crazy not
crazy bad just interesting how it's all
evolved but mostly sci-fi mostly sci-fi
genre fantasy yes things that have some
kind of a you know can at least the
connection to that world right right
um but anyway so so I'd only really done
that and then I was doing Chuck and then
right and then Chuck tied into that
because it's nerd culture and sci-fi
culture and all that kind of stuff and
so I got invited to Birmingham to go to
this convention called star Fury and I
had a lovely time and met not just
wonderful fans but also friends I mean
Felicia Day and I became friends there
Miracle Laurie and I became friends
there
um but uh but I I realized oh and also
we got to this it was really funny
because there was a campaign going on
for Chuck at the time I think because I
think it was like the end of the second
season or something and there was a big
fan campaign to like save the show
Subway was one of our main sponsors and
even like product placement tie-ins we
had it on the show all the time
it I liked it was a really good product
placement in that we just leaned into it
it was so like winking to the audience
how about that foot long you know as
opposed to like trying to make it subtle
and like as if it's a part of natural
dialogue in a show to talk about any
product for that matter right and we
don't get paid for the commercial anyway
um but but it was really fun because
there was a Subway literally around the
corner the the the the campaign was
happening like right then that weekend
because the finale was was airing
and somebody told me there was a Subway
around the corner and I was like and and
Adam and I we had already done one panel
Adam Baldwin thank you very good uh who
was the illustrious Casey on Chuck
um we had already done one panel and and
it wasn't that small uh that big of a
convention so like everybody who was at
the convention who wanted to go to the
panel basically already saw the panel
and we had one other panel and I said I
said well what if we just like what if
we just like instead of doing the panel
what if we just invited everybody to go
to Starbucks or to uh Subway and I did I
just said hey uh so the foot long finale
is going on right now we've already
talked about all the things we can talk
about who wants to go get a sandwich and
we and I marched everyone how many
people marched with you to Subway 100
maybe about that
marching one by one hurray all the way
from the convention center all the way
and it was close I mean it wasn't like
you know far far away but we had to like
walk across this like you know I don't
know Business Center kind of area you
were Rocky essentially bro way Rocky be
rocking all the way up those steps and
then and then we had a mat by the way
the poor people at Subway had we gave
tried to give them a heads up but they
were still not prepared for the amount
of people that were they were about to
get hit with and so because it was
moving as slowly as it was I was like yo
let me let me get back there so I
started making sandwiches with the
Sandwich Artist by the way I became a
sandwich artist for today wow I know I
know
um but anyway so I say all that to say
it was a really memorable and lovely
time I I I'm so glad that I did it but
one of the things that dawned on me in
that in that weekend was I don't really
have a lot to talk about I don't have a
resume I don't have a I don't have a
career in this particular World sci-fi
genre fantasy nerd culture whatever
um to sit at a table not that I wasn't
worthy anybody's worthy of going and
sitting at that table if you've been
invited or whatever and you want to go
sit there but to me I felt like I want
to go build a bit more of this stuff
they'll come back so when people come to
the table they have multiple things that
they might have enjoyed of of mine in it
tangled and Shazam sure yeah and the
football movie The American Underdog
American Underdog but that's not real I
mean by the way people still do come to
conventions and have me sign their
little Rams helmet so again conventions
transcend even genre at this point
they're really just
their entertainment conventions often
you know not that genre or or sci-fi and
all that stuff doesn't still take you
know the Lion's Share of what all of it
all of it is and and rightfully so
um but yeah I mean the marvelism is
maisel I mean like all these the random
things that I've done you've done a [__]
ton of stuff since Chuck well I've done
a good amount of things since Chuck but
and even during Chuck but anyway the
point is all those things
apply to the experience and therefore
make it a more enjoyable experience for
the fan and for myself and so yeah I
don't know that's why I agree I agree
it's it's definitely but that makes it's
a perfect reason that's why you took a
Hiatus 10 years and then sort of like
okay now I have a bunch of stuff and I
think you know it's just it's just more
to talk about exactly different projects
yeah I could I don't feel like I'm just
talking about the same thing over and
over I think that's smart and now you're
at a place where you know you're a big
movie star and things have changed um
I hope not I know it's good though
especially since you know 2007 was Chuck
Chuck ended when 2012 2012. yeah but
since 12 you got to think from 12 to now
10 years like how much you've changed in
how much do you think you've changed
mentally in terms of Mental Health
oh certainly well I mean listen I I hope
I you know to your comment before I I
hope I haven't changed at all when it
comes to whatever the good the good like
with any of us I hope that none of the
good qualities in us change yeah the
good qualities hopefully not only never
change but only become more polished and
and and more capable of of creating more
positivity in your own life and the
lives of those around you
um but yeah I also hope we very much
change with all the other stuff and to
that point I mean dude I it's I'm a
I am the same person and I am a
completely different person when it
comes to mental and emotional well-being
and understanding of my mental and
emotional health you know yeah I mean
all the things we've talked about on
this very podcast before you know the
Journey of all of it the you've been on
the most by the way you have you're the
you uh what's the word you sir you
surpass surpassed uh uh a ml Eclipse Tom
Welling oh you are I think this is good
I think this is the fifth or sixth five
five this is five I think well we also
the we add if you want to add to that
part one that we had the therapist our
therapist come on and talk with us where
you came on for like 10 minutes okay so
maybe six maybe six sort of six but
anyway
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection if you had to
pinpoint like or one specific thing and
maybe this is too vague and you'll have
to elaborate on it but what has changed
mostly in the last 10 years for you
um in terms of your mental well-being
what is the one thing that you notice
you're just stronger about maybe
handling things handling life will get
into your I know your dad is sick right
now Instagram and so it's like I guess
why I'm asking this question is because
I know we've talked about it and you
know you post and you're asking for
prayers and everybody's sending prayers
yeah including me to your father thank
you and thank you to everybody out there
who has been so awesome and so
supportive and so loving and you know
and really
um thoughtful and intentional and
selfless in those moments however
moments that you guys can can can share
and ultimately you know I think just
attention really quickly I think prayer
is a is a beautiful thing even if at the
end of the day
the thing that we are earnestly asking
for and hoping for does not necessarily
manifest
the intention behind it all taking a
moment taking that moment and being of
service in your energy in your spirit in
your heart in your mind outside of you
that is good for you it is good for them
it is good for us as a collective and
there really is I believe energetically
and there's so much science behind this
too I don't know if you're familiar with
um Dr Joe dispenza or people like do you
know them I know of them I mean I want
to get Joe dispense on the podcast he's
so amazing yeah it's a really
interesting cat I've never I I don't
like follow him intently I have one of
his books I have yet to get through
um but
um I bring him up because I think that
he is a representative of a very real
thing which is energetic kind of
manifestation which by the way is prayer
that it's all the same thing this thing
that for you know eons for thousand
Millennia we as human beings have had
this practice of Prayer of collect
active like intention setting and
believing faith in like this thing's
gonna happen and mind over matter and if
you do that intently enough and truly
enough you know Jesus in the Bible talks
about faith the size of a mustard seed
like but that but real faith we all you
know to believe like I believe this
could happen as opposed to that shit's
happening like there's a difference in
that and the people that do that the
most effectively literally [__] do
miraculous things they change their own
body chemistry they're able to help
others change their body chemistry but
our ability to think our way and I know
it sounds like pseudoscience nonsense
and trust me I'm I'm not an expert on
any of this but I fully fully believe
because the data does I mean dispenza
has real data he he he they put monitors
on people they test their bloods and all
these things and there are people that
you can see very clearly that are
transitioning from a very unhealthy mind
heart Spirit body and you see all the
man all the bad stuff manifesting in
their body because they're bad thought
processes I believe all that and then if
you have a good thought process you can
manifest the good things so anyway
prayer though for all those of the more
religious side of what manifests and
you're not like you're not a big
advocate for organized religion and all
that you're more about no you're not
yeah no not really yeah no I mean well
we'll unpack that too but um no but but
I do think that as a concept I think
that prayer is real and what we're
seeing is that it's scientifically being
validated so whether you want to believe
it's coming through God through Jesus or
or or or or Muhammed or actually Allah
is not Muhammed because Muhammad was the
prophet but through Jesus God through
through uh or just spiritual
energy or by the way even if you're just
a total atheist and all you believe in
is science there's science behind it so
there's something there to just you got
to believe in something there's
something to appreciate behind that and
I and I think it's worth all of our time
to allow ourselves to investigate that
and really unpack that idea yeah whether
you're a spiritual person or not and I
do and from my perspective I'm both a
spiritual person and a person of Science
and I really think that all of the
evidence is there enough for me to go
it's real there's something real there
and it's not just for the person that we
are praying for it is for the collective
it is for our Collective edification do
you guys hear that what he's saying in a
nutshell
layman's terms right here folks I'm
Gonna Give You layman's terms he's
saying that it's science to actually uh
it does it's not just good for the
person that you're maybe praying or
thinking about or giving this energy and
thought to but it's actually good for
you it's good for the mind and what he's
saying is it's science he's got like Joe
guys like Joe yeah and go check it out
you know check it out on your own but
like but look it's it can't be a bad
thing I have friends that are atheists
and they're like I don't believe God I'm
atheist I go I don't believe you're an
atheist
you may not believe in God but I don't
believe that you're an atheist like what
do you mean I go I just think that you
have to have belief in something I don't
think we could survive if we don't you
have to have faith in something yeah but
but by definition atheist means no no
God I mean it's like you know so they
are you can't take away I don't I by the
way there are atheists who's starting
who are starting to
[__] with the definition of atheism and
say it's almost like agnosticism and I
don't think that's fair I think I don't
think that's fair to agnostics like so
you think it should be black or white it
should be this or you no no no no no no
what I'm saying is that if you believe
in a particular Faith deity religion
whatever that's you that's how you
define yourself okay if you want to
Define yourself as an atheist by all
means that's your prerogative and your
life and whatever but as an atheist own
that that means I am choosing to not
believe in God I am making the I a
person of Faith chooses to have faith
yeah
atheist chooses to have faith in the
lack of God their their decision is they
have because they don't have any proof
right we don't have any proof one way or
the other so you are like you're saying
you have to have faith in that but they
are by definition they are taking the
stance I do not believe uh so therefore
I believe in no God I don't believe in
God so therefore I I believe in no God
right that's atheism what I don't like
and well and then quickly in an
agnosticism is just they I don't know I
don't know I don't know one way or the
other and the doubt sure but I doubt
it's the middle round it's that middle
ground and and to be perfectly honest I
feel like all of us ought to be a little
bit more like that because I think that
anytime human beings say oh I've got the
answer it is one of the most arrogant
things that ever comes out of your house
it's so dangerous and it's full of so
much hubris and the power that comes
behind one's ability to then convince
other people of whatever the [__] you
believe yeah that's that's like that's
the thing that's where sick is really
wacky and I think that if we all had a
bit more humility in this world and in
this life we would all be a bit more
agnostic because what the [__] do we
know we don't know [__] anything we
are these itty little teeny bitty things
how many societies have been ostracized
murdered all through like what I think
is right and you're wrong and you will
die no I think I think again I wasn't
there the Inception of any of these
religions I don't know but but I but I
think that
like most things most I I don't maybe
not mostly but but you had you had
people that were trying to figure some
[__] out I mean you go back far enough
we were tribal shamanic you know there
are still some of those peoples now but
it was way more we were all much more
there was more mysticism in all of it
which is the cool [__] that's the
spiritual [__] that's by the way you
know there have been mistakes of all the
religions and the mystics all get
together and hang out they don't hate
each other you ever I think I've talked
about the Enneagram on this podcast but
that all comes from mysticism of all the
religions it was the the Jewish
Christian Muslim Buddhists like all of
those Mystics basically all agreed that
the Enneagram was a real thing it wasn't
they weren't all attacking each other
and being like well I don't believe in
your version of God they're all like
okay we all have these different
opinions we'll table those for now but
look at this [__] cool thing holy
[__] this is some real [__] right so I
do think if you go back far enough you
had you know much smaller groups of
people that were trying to find
understanding and and and not just
understanding but have appreciation and
gratitude toward the existence that they
had and the connection they have to the
universe as a whole and also they
weren't like they would see things in
the sky like shoot across the sky and
not know think it's some other what is
that is that a God so there's a lot of
just like uncertainty put it put a pin
put a pin in comments though because I
actually want I but I also want to get
back like we're going down we're already
going down rabbit yeah but I do I
definitely want to get there's something
I do want to talk yeah well so let's
remember these put a pin in in meteor's
comments I want to talk about that
um but then yeah going coming back just
really quickly to just tie
um a ribbon on something
if you're atheist you're you are you are
believing in not God if you're if you
are religious you are believing in God
if but I don't think as an atheist
because I've seen a lot of I've seen not
a lot I've seen some uh arguments that
atheists are making and basically
calling themselves agnostics and it's
like well then call yourself agnostic
then say you don't know there's not
enough evidence to prove one way or the
other yeah but it to call yourself an
atheist it's like you're saying no I
believe not God I'm believing in the end
and again you to you I have I really
don't have any
um desire to try and uh move somebody
off of that if they don't want to move
off of that sure but I will always want
to talk about what I believe to be
evident in this world in a very real
tangible visceral scientifically you
know um governed World these energy
things are real they are real and they
are and they are markable we are or
remarkable they are are
um one of my uh uh calculable they are
measure durable there there's data that
can that can support these things and I
think it's in all of our best interest
to collectively go down that road and
figure out what that is because I think
that's where all the good good is that's
what I agree it is I know collectively
we can all be on that same page I also
think that
look I don't know a lot about religion I
couldn't even start talking to you about
my own religion I'm not religious I it
was Bar Mitzvah I probably did it for
the money I don't know uh I respect my
religion uh you know you do make a lot
of money in apartments but well you did
but I think my dad you know what you
think you're dead Captain I don't
remember no I used to I used to DJ
weddings and Byron bought meds I could
see that he's singing all that but
listen I it's so weird maybe I'm just a
feeble-minded uh not incredibly educated
sort of just
averagely smart intellectual person
maybe I'm creative maybe but look I'm a
very creative person but I also think I
just sit there and I think
and this is there's no scientific proof
there obviously but I just keep
rewinding rewinding to the beginning and
I keep saying
so it just it all just happened
that's what I keep going back to it all
just happened we just just single cell
organisms and then it kind of
came and that's just it there's no
reason then we fast forward millions of
years and we just and we're just all
evolving and then there's other species
out there and there's other and this was
just no one thought about this no one
said this is what why is there but first
of all people say
why is there Blackness why is there even
Blackness why was Blackness created I
mean the void the Voice
who created the why is there nothing why
is there shouldn't be anything if
there's nothing right
so where the void what what but then
what space does the void even even exist
in if there is right but then what
contradicts that or you know makes me
think okay maybe I'm wrong because I go
all the way back and then I go okay you
know there's there's God and then God
did it all and created darkness and the
void and then the the Earth all these
planets crashed in meteors and it
created Earth over millions of years and
then Dinosaurs and Ice Ages and all this
[__] until we are here now I'm like who
created God though right it just keeps
going [__] back dude so I don't know
all I know is like it's the great
Celestial chicken and egg and I don't
know why but it's it's sort of how I
just feel yeah and some people don't
feel that at all and they're like no God
there's this movie called 30 days a
night and there's these vampires and the
only lines they say in the whole movie
is one two words the woman goes oh God
and the vampire looks at and goes no God
no God that's it they don't say another
word anyway don't they say there is no
God no no God no God no God oh [__] oh
that's even more terrible creepy but
listen I do want to get because we can
go on about this and you know and I want
to connect I mean that's why I'm here I
I know but but what I do want to say is
you know when I was thinking the
question was like how have you changed
in the last 10 years
um
but the reason I said it is because I
wonder how Zach would have uh
uh how he would have been affected by
his dad being in hospital and dying and
all these things going on if this was 10
years ago oh like how much have you
evolved or how much have you gotten
mentally stronger yeah to make you give
you coping abilities and not to say you
can prepare but so understand what's
going on no totally totally what's the
deal like what's the difference well I
mean listen look it and I've said this
before on the podcast it all starts with
self-love all of it all of it I mean
maybe I'm generalizing here maybe
um but what does self-love have to do
with well let me get there right all
right Rosenbaum Jesus
so listen listen listen
in order for us I believe in order for
us to
to have deep amounts of
patience
fortitude
Grace
uh kindness strength
confidence
decision making in that from that
confidence all of all of the attributes
I believe all of the attributes that are
really the attributes that we're seeking
that we want peace
we're all really ultimately we want to
[__] feel peace we want we don't want
to be in a state of fight or flight
which we're all in all the time our
society is built for it put a pin in
that [__] but uh but in order to feel
all those things on the best deepest
healthiest level
starts with you believing that you
deserve to feel all those things on that
level and if you don't love yourself
truly love yourself
then you don't make that space not
the time not the energy that you put
toward yourself not the again you have
to practice all those things with
yourself in order for you to practice
them well with others you know on the
deepest level you know who talks about
that in their book you me your book yeah
yeah yes which is awesome which by the
way you guys should get it where do they
get the book uh radical love you can get
it online it's uh well unfortunately
it's still not International I I for
anybody who is watching the podcast from
outside of the US I've been trying to
get harpercollins and and the folks to
figure out how to get it to other
countries because it's just not
available particularly
um even if at the very least getting the
audible uh or the book to other
English-speaking countries because you
read you're the Audio I read the audio
yeah I read I read the audio
um but I wanted I want to get it even
translated I understand that there are
costs associated with doing all the
translation and the markets have to
Warrant that like you know there have to
be enough people calling up their book
companies in Brazil or Italy or wherever
and saying yeah and saying hey we really
want this book and then if there's
enough of that demand then they are they
call harpercons I'm like yeah we got a
lot of people that want this book
um but at the very least there's no
costs in translational translational
costs to go to other English speaking or
even even countries that have a lot of
English-speaking people in them if they
want to sell you know it's easy there's
no just make it available it's digital
for God's sake I mean it's like it's not
radical love radical love Yeah radical
and so all right so get back to
you're saying in order to do all these
things to have a peace and and strength
for all these things yes I don't I don't
see how it works any other way but don't
you think that I look around me and I
hate to use celebrities as an example
but I see a lot of people that I'm like
they don't love themselves they're
horrible people they're whatever and
they're successful and they're doing all
their things and they're walking on
people and they don't give a [__] what
do you think they actually love each
other that love themselves
I don't think success
and self-love are the same the mutually
or or they are mutually exclusive or you
know what I mean like
he
there are I mean it's unfortunate I wish
karmically that the world worked faster
that our existence worked faster I wish
that people doing shitty things felt the
brunt of that [__] faster it would
course correct a lot of people a lot a
lot more quickly I suppose you know and
maybe make it but that's just not how it
works and so yeah you could be very
successful and be a douchebag you could
be very successful and treat people very
poor and very successful and not love
yourself yeah sure yes yeah of course
but
uh
but I but I don't think again successes
success is a great marker sometimes I
think I've become more every time I go
and actually truly
show up for myself
uh um love myself look at areas of my
life that I need to like yo I need to be
smarter about this I need to be stronger
about this I need to be better about
this and I need to do it and I need to
keep that promise to myself every time I
do that in my life that's when really
wonderful things happen so I do think
that success can be a marker of you
loving yourself of doing the work that
real work the internal work that you
need to do right I agree with that I
think that I really believe that being
I'll just say that being a good person
and being generous and being humble and
um altruistic and all these things it if
nothing makes you just feel better and
makes you love yourself I think it's
helpful more I think it's helpful but I
guess what I would I would even go a
step further and say Focus less about
being generous and focus more about
again loving yourself and accepting
yourself and the more you're able to do
that the more you're able to do it with
other people the more the more you're
willing to accept that like oh my God I
I I
[__] up all the time and there are so
many things that I would rail you know
like my self-talk was so bad and all
that jazz that as soon as I just started
saying like hey it's not your fault
it's you know like straight up out of
Jerry Maguire or um now of a Goodwill
Hunting uh you know Robin Williams
looking at at Will Hunting saying uh at
uh Matt Damon it's not your fault it's
not your fault
that's true
but that means it's true of everyone
every single person it's interesting
person and you're saying so and so hear
me out so the internal work is
recognizing that
you want to be generous yes generosity
as an act is a beautiful thing a
beautiful thing and everyone should do
it we're almost regardless of your
motive go be generous and by the way
generosity uh uh um then uh you know um
brings out gratitude and you know
gratitude scientific that's so cool
watch not even if you are practicing
gratitude brain changes dude if you
watch someone else show gratitude it's
almost more powerful than you your own
gratitude practice isn't that crazy yeah
if you watch out you know somebody help
an old lady did you see it well sure but
and and it encourages it in you you are
seeing example in the wild and go that
is good that is good to do and you want
somebody walking old lady across the
street and you see the old lady oh thank
you so much that's hugely powerful for
your own edification your own real quick
okay and then remember what you're gonna
say because otherwise I'm going to
forget this yeah
but unfortunately
and you could help me out here
I feel that in order to love myself
I just if I'm more giving and I'm more
generous and I'm good to people and
maybe I'll I'll feel that maybe I'll
love myself more and unfortunately that
doesn't work and that's what I'm saying
it's not that's an outside in approach I
know but I I I I try to find that
because I my analogy would be this is a
bad analogy but like let's say you're
I'm not but let's say you're you're uh
let's say in your life you've killed
some people okay and nobody knows about
it right I haven't killed anybody but
this is a bad analogy no no you've
killed people then you're like you know
what I'm not gonna kill anybody anymore
but I can't love myself because I've
killed before
okay
does that make sense to you it does I
don't that's a s that is a end of a
spectrum that I have a very hard time I
think I'm a don't use kill use uh let's
just say
um let's say I don't know it's fine I
understand what you're saying you say
what I'm saying I totally understand
yeah okay I I get it so how does someone
love themselves when they know some of
the things they've done aren't lovable
well
let me go next book let me let me let me
finish to the next book let me finish
this thought first Okay the reason I'm
even bringing that up about is because
I think it is it is far more uh
um when you work from the inside out the
the the generosity flows out you're not
trying to be generous to be a good
person you become a good and good and
bad person I I I mean healed more healed
more awake more aware more more capable
all of that you know but when you become
more of that by loving yourself by
radically accepting forgiving and loving
yourself
then what happens is automatically you
recognize as a logical person hopefully
you're a person you know that exercises
logic that in order to apply that to you
you have to apply to everyone else
because this logic is the same we are
all products of our environment that is
the [__] logic that's what it is so
if you are a murderer I don't know why
you've killed people but every scenario
I haven't killed
I know yeah
the Royal weed the Royal the editorial
wave
you know this is a very complicated Case
Model A lot of ins a lot of outs a lot
of what happens
um
stay away from my special lady friend
listen
um what was I talking about oh yeah the
so you have to buy logic you have to see
so if you're a murderer
I would say chances are
you've killed because
of
whatever programming you got in your
life from birth to the point that you
killed and that doesn't excuse it it
doesn't excuse any of it it explains it
and we should all want the explanation
because the explanation gives us the why
and the why allows us to see the human
inside of the murderer and not
dehumanize them at the same time and and
if being able we can do that we can see
the human in there we can still hold
them accountable
have Grace for them and love for them
now some say well they had a fine
childhood and you know Dahmer whatever I
don't know listen there are sociopaths
and Psychopaths that are born into this
world there are there are and they
required very little or maybe maybe even
no abuse that led them there but I would
say that that means they were still born
cellularly molecularly biologically they
were born with a you know a little off
they're all screw loose they still
inherited that [__] it wasn't their
fault which doesn't excuse Dahmer going
and [__] literally murdering people
and eating them crazy horrible that's
evil [__]
but the essence the the kernel of where
it all started is supposed to be a far
better existence hopefully for every
child as they come into the world and so
they don't end up in that place but even
if you don't end up becoming a murderer
it's a it's the whole scale your
programming leads you to be this or that
or whatever all the way up to these far
extremes and all of it is on that same
place of guess what yes you're
responsible for your actions you must
pay consequences for your actions but
you are not actually at fault for if
we're looking at some like larger moral
sin versus you know not sin or whatever
like guys yes there's sinful acts and
there's evil acts and and all that [__]
but you have to we have to recognize
that people are all it sounds crazy but
everyone's doing the best they can with
the tools they have at that moment so so
hear me out so here we go
so I told you this would be heavy so you
do that work you're if you're doing that
work on yourself that means in order to
really do the work on yourself that
means you have to it forces you to look
at your parents to look at your family
to look at your friends to look at your
enemies to look at anyone look at your
other people in other places in the
world and whatever even historically and
look at them all As
children of God of the universe of we're
all we're all they started and got
[__] they started and got [__] in a
way and
I can't have Grace with them I can have
peace with them and I think
and again not absolving them of their
responsibility right but understanding
that there's way bigger deeper things
going on and when we can do that deep
work guess what
you want to be generous
you want to be loving you want to be
patient you want to be kind you want
those people to understand that you see
the human in them because that's the way
we get them back
that's the way that they become the
better version of who they are
and we can't do that
truthfully we can't do that with
authenticity we can't do that
unless we've loved our self first so
have you gone through this have you gone
through a part where there's listen have
you ever thought
when you're talking to your therapist
when you're talking to when you go on
that rehab center like that yeah yeah
and we went away and we talked to people
was it easy for you to say I there's
nothing this is like is it was this your
belief there's nothing you can say right
now nothing will make me love myself I
cannot love myself I there's nothing I
can do I just don't feel like I I'm
worthy of loving myself yeah have you
ever thought that all the time I mean
yes well yeah that's what drove me to
that place to begin with I didn't want
to live yeah I didn't but but I also
didn't even understand really truly
understand what self-love was I didn't
understand what love was
I was 37 years old I really didn't
understand the concept of actual love I
understood whatever I thought love was
you know and I think we all have ideas
of what we think love is
and still it's a very amorphous you know
uh beautiful powerful amazing amazing
word term definition entity energy Love
Is Love Is Love is Like the highest
vibrational level of God like it's where
we I think we're all being pulled toward
where we're all supposed to be walking
but we can't love if we're still shaming
we can't love if we're still shaming if
we're still hating if we're still afraid
of each other because of all the
[__] that we've been programmed to
believe to be afraid of each other that
breeds that hate
you know what I mean it's it's so it's
so sad but again that's but guess what
you're not able to be programmed with
hate
if you've already filled yourself what
what real love is because you identify
the charlatans you know when people are
trying to just rile you up to be angry
with someone else for a thing that that
other person's afraid of
it it's insanity but so you become more
aware in all of that so to wrap all that
up then to come back to your question
about like my dad
10 years ago
if this was happening 10 years ago so
many different variables would be going
on my dad would have been living in
North Carolina at the time
um my mom would have been alive my mom
would have been alive my sisters would
uh one would have been married neither
of them would have would have had any
kids right
um uh it was 2020 to 2013. I would have
just had been finishing Chuck was not by
the way in a in a very good well I
wasn't in the worst pla I had a wider
ways to go down into the darkness from
well all along that time but were you
ready for well listen
I would have been I would have been okay
I mean I'm okay right now
I love my dad but my dad wasn't in my
life my whole life I mean really I saw
my dad two weeks a year and we would
talk on Sundays sometimes for like five
ten minutes my dad would call it
swapping howdies
and not that my dad wasn't there to give
me wisdoms along the way and love along
the way and encouragements and stuff and
I and I'm very appreciative why why was
it so intermittent well because my mom
and dad divorced when I was six and then
my mom remarried my stepdad and moved us
up to Seattle my dad's job was
relocating to North Carolina and my dad
was like well I guess I'll only see the
kids a little bit anyway and he [__]
off and went to North Carolina and he
worked for that company for another like
25 why did you forgive him or have you
obviously you have oh yeah well I think
that I forgave my dad I mean it's a
process you know like healing is a
process yeah it's not always like and I
forgave him then it's like I I am
forgiving I am healing it's a journey
and that's okay it's actually kind of
beautiful in that way you know and the
the pressure of like I got to get to
this Monumental moment and look
sometimes it is sometimes it is this
massive moment or or at least moments
yeah and they're so cathartic I mean
even when I flew in my Dad's health took
a real bad turn last week uh Saturday
yeah so not this past Thursday but the
Thursday before
I was supposed to come to LA and be here
uh for a little bit anyway starting on
the 18th but my sister texted me two
Thursdays ago and she's like yo can you
get here now because we're not even sure
dad's gonna make it through the night
and so I flew to LA and I got my rental
car and I was driving from Ventura to LA
and I just
you know kept the radio off it was a
drive I knew very very well going from
LA to Ventura in Ventura to LA that's
where I grew up and you know and um and
I've had a lot of Journeys up and down
the 101 and no radio on and just like
lost in thought and really kind of
meditation you know when you go to that
kind of Flow State of thought you're
almost kind of in a meditative State and
that brings a lot of like
um I don't know like almost then they
can bring on almost like a prayer State
like a connected State and then that
opens up catharsis and that opens up
empathy and I just cried I just drove
and I cried almost this on two Thursdays
ago I just drove just cry yeah what were
you thinking about when you were crying
I don't know just like
like did you ever think of like of what
could have been or it could have been
different I do not do that no I let go
of that alone you do but you have to you
have to I mean you don't have to you can
hold on to [__] for the rest of your
life but let me tell you
not worth it and the reason why we hold
on to it is because we we're still
living in this place of like but it you
know what it should have could us like
you got to let go of the [__] what it
should have cut us though they didn't
bottom line there is no and we will and
we'll I mean I still do I still do so
sad what just hearing you say that not
not even about you or me of letting go
of the what I should have coulda's
yeah it's almost like of course you have
to it's unhealthy but at the same time
when you let go of that there really is
no hope there's all there's only reality
and sometimes reality is not as good as
false hope
I don't know no I think I don't know
either maybe I shouldn't have said I
think no no no not at all listen that
you're absolutely entitled to whatever
that that thought is that's an
interesting path down that thought
process you know we're just we're just
unpacking I want to get to where you are
because
my uncle said something to me he said uh
you know you see a therapist right like
yeah and he goes good I just think you
know you should be talking about
your mom with I go well I always tell
you not talking about my family and you
know obviously you know and not as much
anymore but like she's like yeah I just
I I don't know how it's going to affect
you when your mom passes and
um that hit me really hard because I
thought
I don't really see her very often and
I've given her everything I bought her a
house and I've helped her and constantly
and yeah you know I just it's a you know
I love my mother but I'm not but you
know it's so weird and I started to
think
like of getting that call
like someone calling saying hey
you know your mom passed and
even saying that I get a little numb
yeah and I don't know how I'll deal with
it because there are certain things
between my mother and father
between me and my mother myself and my
father that will never ever be
resolved because
of really good reasons and a lot of
people say there's no good reasons
they're all
all reason there should be no reasons
you should always clear the air you
should always say
it's it's
I know I sound
they're just two people that I can't
really get close to I just can't you
don't need to I love them and I'm I'll
do anything for them but
um it's just hard to really I I don't
feel vulnerable I can't open up and they
won't and it doesn't feel real you don't
need to so I just I worry about myself
you know when the time happens if I'll
be okay well
I I would encourage you to
I would encourage you to recognize that
[Music]
um
again the more you go and work on you
the more you'll be able to radically
accept forgive and love them okay which
still does not equate to you have to be
close to them which still does not
equate to you have to just give them
carp launch access into your life in any
way shape or form none of those things
equate to each other you know what I'm
saying
and it's not about that it's not a it's
not a
being able to I think being able to
handle a death or really anything but
you know involving any of this kind of
stuff the the best way to be able to
handle it
is it's not that
it's not that you have to somehow get
everything healed so much that you're
close again and you're like oh I love
you like oh my God like that kind of
love that's not what it is
you have to you have to uh relinquish
this idea that you're responsible for
them first and foremost you're not
responsible for that that's it at all
um so you know what I mean like I mean
we have some responsibility as human
beings to one another but like up to
whatever that responsibility is
um up to up to that point that's not
yours to that's not your burden to care
always feel a burden with with many
things because
I I just I've always been okay but then
all of my problems right but that's
something you need to be working on I
know that is a big thing you need to be
working on because you're just you're
carrying a load that's not yours bud
with your parents with anything else in
your life understand what's yours and
understand what's not that is one of the
first rules of loving yourself that's
boundaries that's boundaries so so you
you've got that but then also recognize
that I think that the hardest seemingly
I mean I I can't think of something else
but like seemingly the hardest thing
about losing someone in your life
is if
there hasn't been
not the repairing of the relationship
but the healing of the heart
the healing of the heart
don't be stressing about I need to
repair this relationship go heal your
heart
and when you heal your heart the way
that you will see your mom when she
ultimately passes will be a healthier
happier
more peaceful heart to take on that
entire
experience whatever that's going to be
at that point in your life that's how
you prepare for it I feel like I'm I
again twofold
my dad
wasn't really in my life I love him I
mean I talk about it in my book I you
know he's he's been more a part of our
lives in the last five six years since
he retired and moved out to LA and then
moved to Ventura yeah yeah
um and his heart has always been I
really believe in the right place I
really do my I do think my dad's heart's
always been in the right place but my
dad and my mom
they came together to create me and my
sisters and I'm grateful for that but
Lord they did not belong together as a
relationship and it really and you know
and and I've been able to look at my dad
since going through a lot of this
therapy I've been able to look at my dad
through the lens of recognizing that he
was a product of his environment and
just seeing the little boy in him to see
the little boy look at your mom see the
little girl in her look at your dad and
she hasn't grown up since 16 years old
well bro okay okay but but but there you
go and recognizing that oh man oh like
Let Your Heart Break for that it has
yeah and then in that then you go oh
there's some Grace there's some empathy
there's some love there's some there's
some things but there's also
manipulation bro but listen understood
but that's not understand that the
manipulation is her trying to survive
my mom was literally the I mean a master
manipulator like oh my God like she
could [__] sell ice to a [__]
Eskimo you know what I mean like it was
incredible the way that she could pull
on people's hearts I mean eventually
that people started you hopefully people
start recognizing the manipulative games
and they all start Burning Bridges and
all that [__] you know what I mean which
was really sad for my mom was hard but
she wasn't manipulating people because
she wanted to be a bad person your mom
is not manipulating you or anyone else
because she's actually like twisting her
Machiavellian mustache and being like
no she's manipulating because she's
trying to [__] survive because that's
what she learned which doesn't absolve
it of or her of her responsibility and
the and the consequences of it which
means you don't have to have a
relationship with her
but heal your [__] heart
and heal it by recognizing that it's not
intentional it's not personal it's none
of those things she's just scared little
girl
we're all just scared little kids
all of the ways we hurt other people all
the [__] that we do in the world
it's just a scared little kid in there
which sounds [__] again
woo-wooy and no whatever but but I mean
honestly if you just break it down on a
psychological level [__] Freud and
young and all of it they all say the
same goddamn thing basically they point
to the same thing those guys were really
really smart young I think particularly
and all I mean by the way
so much of this stuff you can look back
at you know like uh
um stoicism I mean there's so many of
these wisdoms that are even found and
that kind of stuff but really the way
that the human psyche has been broken
down and we understand how we work if we
really all went by that as the North
Star and we took that as real textbook
science and we all looked at each other
through the eyes of that holy [__] this
world would be so much better but again
not just the science but the love you
know you gotta go with that love it's
not just even recognizing that somebody
is a scared little child it's having a
love for that child it's recognizing
that they are deserving of the love that
they didn't get which is why they are I
think that's why you and I
understand each other you it's amazing
hearing you because it's it's like
you're telling me everything that's so
obvious but I've never really heard it
so I've never heard this from therapists
or your your analogy not even your
analogy but the reality of what it is
about that little girl and all these
things and it's just powerful like I've
never received what I just received from
you ever that made absolute sense I
don't know why well because you're very
articulate and you've and you know this
and you've lived this but I just I it's
it's so profound
to me to hear that because I just didn't
understand it I'll say things to my
brother and I go this and this and my
sister and well you know my brother and
we'll just but never has someone put it
out there where it was a defense
defending thing it was more like not
that you're defending her actions or
whatever but defending that this is this
is her surviving this is all that I mean
it's just it's well let me it's insanely
profound to me like I was looking at you
just like I felt like I wasn't even here
like this is one of the first times
where I'm I'm talking to you and I'm
like oh I gotta be the interview here
and I honestly was just like
well oh my god well bless you man thank
you I can see you were getting a little
emotional because you were talking about
you too but as a kid absolutely but but
I'm gonna I
I I I think the the reason why that
might have felt different
than other therapies or things or maybe
you haven't heard that or whatever
um is because
well because of God and and let me
explain
you go to most therapy previous Swiss
previous West was an incredible place to
go incredible and the battery of
therapists and and professionals that
helped me to get into a healthier place
in my life and give me tools to go and
continue to survive and thrive in my
life so grateful for that but if it were
it not for
Beth in the book her her name is not
Beth but were it not for best I know who
you're talking about you know what I'm
talking about were it not for her and
really breaking the protocol the
protocol that could have got her fired
and I'm glad that she wasn't I'm glad
that that Heidi and you know that
everybody understood how important that
was but
it it took her loving by the way a woman
of God a woman who is deeply spiritual
and one of honestly
one of the most truly empathetic not
like oh no no I know did you yeah
yeah so you know so you know what I'm
talking about yes so so for her to take
it upon herself to love on me
and felt by God to do so to pray for me
to love on me right
that is a energy that is love again
talking about the highest vibrational
version of God that is love
as an energy that was being literally
poured through her as a conduit to me to
me
and that and that is The X Factor my
friend The X Factor and I think
difference between going and just having
clinical therapy
and having perhaps in a moment right now
I got to be a conduit by the way I could
feel it not I'm not even kidding when I
I find myself falling into these like
really interesting slip streams
sometimes and I and it's like oh I'm not
even talking right now like this is God
talking through me like I know I'm
saying the words and I know I believe
the words and they're and it's because
I've had these thoughts so you believe
them so yes 100 right bro I believe them
with everything in my heart I feel like
it's part of my entire calling in this
world is to go and help people love
themselves so that we can love each
other God damn it man it's like it's
it's hard it's so goddamn hard but it's
so simple it's so simple if we could
just figure that out if we could just
get there
so I spent a lot of time thinking about
this [__] you know yeah so that's anyway
so that's my way of saying if you're
wondering why that felt different it's
be I think it's because of God I think
it's in moments like that where I get to
be a conduit to just speak something
that I believe to be absolute [__]
Wisdom it is absolute wisdom it is
absolute truth it is absolutely what we
need to do and
I was
someone who was accepting it and
believing everything like it was it
wasn't just we're having a real
conversation yeah yeah yes yes but you
do that's what you do here which is
great you get all kinds of therapy and
and wisdom and all kinds of though
because you have so many people come on
and get to share the things that have
helped them in their life you know and
in doing so helping everybody out there
do it it's wonderful it's awesome
uh so what's going on in your career man
Shazam is coming out March what 17th
March 17th St Patrick's Day Saint
Patrick
Shazam two what's the what's it called
Shazam Shazam 2 Electric Boogaloo no I
wanted it to be though I really did
um no it's Shazam Fury of the Gods
that's what it that's the name of it and
um yeah it's super fun everybody should
go I mean have you seen it yeah oh yeah
you saw it yeah you're smiling it's big
it's big it's bigger than the first oh
it's significantly bigger in in
production and scale and stuff yeah but
also heart it's got a heart well it's
got all all in the first one did it's
got all the
I mean I know I'm biased clearly I mean
I'm as the titular character of of a
movie it's very difficult to not be
biased about your movie but but I think
I try to be
as objective as I can when I can
and you know look I watched it there's
still things I'm like I would have done
that different if I or if I had the edit
I can't remember like this take or
that's it whatever but bro holistically
speaking I mean
it's a better movie than the first one
it is and the first one was a pretty
darn good movie so I think that um
[Music]
I mean honestly like I'm
chomping at the bit for people to go and
see the movie because they're going to
see I really think how are they not
going to see this I hope so I believe so
I don't know bro I don't know all none
of this stuff is written in stone you
don't know these things you just you
gotta
humility gratitude and Trust man be
humble to wherever you're at in your
life and recognize that you are where
you are and try to take that in for what
it is always be grateful for what that
is and Trust I think in God in that
higher power in that energy in in all
that is in and through all things like
the forest trust that [__] and recognize
that the more work you're doing on
yourself the better it's able to help
guide you to those [__] dope places
in your life you know those three things
if the movie does well
like great if it does really well [__]
yeah if it doesn't I'd be I'd be I would
be disappointed and I also be I'd be
surprised because I wouldn't you'd be
strong enough I hope from the therapy I
hope so but you can't remember you can't
validation all these things it doesn't
equate with real love and real so sexual
value as a human values it's hard but
you got typically in our business is
real hard believe because it's so
personal I know so it feels so personal
yeah but anyway so yeah it comes out
March 17th I think radical love is the
book right you guys got to get that if
you're overseas just Instagram him or
tweet him and he'll probably message you
back and say oh get it here or have your
friend get he's trying to get it we're
trying to figure it out and what else is
going on what else I did a movie called
Harold and the Purple Crayon that's
based on the children's book that comes
out in June at some point so that'll be
really interesting and then um
uh what else I don't know I mean there's
work and things that are lining up for
the year I'm gonna go do you just want
to do movies by the way now or would you
do a streaming show uh oh no to me it
doesn't matter what the
what the medium is so much as it man it
matters what the quality of the content
is you know like I was dying to be in
the last of us like I I wanted to see it
I haven't not yet but I've heard it's
great I can't wait to watch it and I'm
stoked for I might listen The Last of Us
video game first and second that whole
franchise some of the best gaming I've
ever had I've never played that game so
I'm not sure but my uh my butt Carter
Swann he's an executive producer I love
you Carter I'm very proud of him yeah I
hope this thing blows the hell up
everybody's loving it oh yeah
and Neil druckman and and everybody at
naughty dog and all the people that are
behind the game like you know it's a and
by the way it's a huge win for video
game content because most series and
movies that come from video games just
haven't really been great they they're
that's true you know it's not it's not
been a very uh successful
um transition and which is unfortunate
because they are so intrinsically
connected particularly now that we have
so many movies and so much content with
CGI and and video game games are the
video game engines are where they're
building it you know I think we're
starting to get into that transitional
phase which is which is great first of
all I want to say thank you because
you're not only a great friend even
though we don't see each other a lot I'm
always there for you you're always there
for me anytime unlike most of my friends
it's and I'm being honest if I text him
and I just say how you doing he'll send
me like a three minute voice message of
his voice and saying what's going on and
how are you I miss you like you always
take time and you don't have to because
I know you're busy sometimes it doesn't
need to happen right away but you're
always
you've just always been such a great
great friend and great great dude you if
anyone deserves the success you have
they have it's you it is you
um you help people you give so much love
I see your Instagrams where you talk to
people and you talked about talk about
faith and you talk about loving yourself
and you talk about you're just
genuinely golden and sometimes I know
you don't like we still fall back into
the self-loathing you know and you just
if you ever think that way you have to
just know that uh look if I like you
I mean [__] dude but look this has been
this has been awesome I never I always
want to have you on every every year I
hope you'll come on and just well you
know I do I love it you do listen man I
I I first of all thank you so much that
those words mean so much to me like
legit legit means something interesting
and I know you do and that's why they
mean something to me you know
um but I've said it before on the
podcast I love coming on because of this
because of this very thing because of if
nothing else we two people that
genuinely care for each other and who
care about unpacking Big Ideas can sit
down and just pick unpack Big Ideas
and that's why I love podcasts so much
you know like it it really has given
people an opportunity look talk shows
and all that stuff and like that can be
fun I guess but it's all canned it's all
like super like crunched you know you're
doing a bit you're doing a thing and
that can be fun but you don't actually
have to have a real [__] conversation
and I think that's why by the way I
think that's why podcasts are have blown
up because we need deeper [__]
conversations we need we've lived in
this bite-sized disposable content
don't talk to him for three minutes yeah
and it's about nothing about nothing you
know and those are great yeah but we're
starving of course of course but we're
starved for we have been starved for
real meaty deeper conversation and
that's what podcasts provide and that's
what yours provides in the Spades I
think the most so thank you thank you
and I think I think the one word if it's
a word relatability that's a word I
think people when they listen I think a
lot of people go oh Rose mom's got who's
Rosenbaum and he's got his celebrity
podcast and but when people listen to it
and they act actually come to me and
they spread the word they're like this
isn't a celebrity this is like you're
really trying to find something out to
help someone who's listening or yourself
or and and that's
it's purpose in a lot of way this this
podcast is inadvertently given me
purpose I never thought it was going to
be a podcast about mental health or
talking about adversity I never I
thought it was just gonna be hey so
anyway yeah let's talk about and all of
a sudden vulnerability hit and it opened
up and and uh you're one of the people
that really got this thing started from
the beginning with opening up and
talking about your mom and you haven't
heard the other episodes you're in for a
treat I love you thanks for allowing to
be inside it's the sixth time oh man and
every time you're inside me it gets a
little bit easier
and a little limper because I'm 50.
I'll see you later love you buddy
always good always great he's been on
more than anyone he now tops the Stephen
Amell and Welling as most appearances
really yep
um
you know I think Jared's been on three
times in Jensen they've each been out
three times so they're up there
um
who else who else has been on welding's
been on like three or four times
you've had Erica Durance a couple times
has been on twice a Christian's been on
two or three times three times I think
um so anyway thank you Zach Levi uh if
you're just listening and you didn't
listen to the intro there's a lot of
great stuff on there where me and Tom
are going to be signing autographs and
where to get our new CD and blah blah
blah all that stuff
um but again I couldn't do this without
the top tier patrons who I'm going to
read off now so these are the top tier
patrons uh patreon.com inside of you if
you want to join if you want to give to
the podcast and keep it going um without
you guys I couldn't do it here we go
Nancy D Leah s Sarah V little Lisa
Yukiko Jill e Bryan H Nico P Robert B
Jason W Sophie m
Kristen Kruk no Kristen K another
Kristin K Raj C Raj you've been here a
long time hi Raj Joshua D Jennifer and
Stacy L has been here and Jamal F and
Janelle B Kimberly e Mike e l Don
Supremo 99 more Santiago am Chad W
Leanne P Janine are all these names see
I read them off now and just like
they've been around for I mean years
it's it's Insanity that I'm not saying
you shouldn't do it I'm saying it's
insane how supportive and amazing you
are and when I read these names off it's
like you've been with me since the
beginning
that it's it's it's cool I'm very lucky
and I I really hope you're still
enjoying the podcast if not write in and
say hey you've lost it it's just the
interviews it's all about the interview
so if you know if you like the
interviews this other [__] that I'm
talking right now like you know in the
intros that's it it's not as important
as the information you get from the
guests and I don't think anybody wants
to really hear me Babble on like I'm
doing Maya P Maddie s Belinda and Chris
H Dave H Sheila G Brad
D correct Ray H Tabitha T I'm going to
come to Japan sometime right I will I'll
see you and your husband and maybe your
baby
Tom that was creepy Tom and Liliana a
Talia and Betsy D hi Betsy where are you
are we zooming or what you supposed to
zoom with us cancel I think you were
sick Chad B Dan and big Stevie W Angel C
Cory K Deb Nixon Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy D Camille ask Joey M Eugene and
Leah how's that little baby Corey
Heather Locklear Heather L Jake B Megan
T Mel s Orlando C Caroline R Christine s
Eric H Shane R Emma R Andrew M zaduichi
77 Andreas and Oracle Karina and hi
Karina Amanda R
gen B Kevin e Stephanie K Lena 82
Jarrell Billy s jam and Jay Leanne J
Luna R Cindy e Mike F Stone H Brian L
Cameron e Katie B Aaron R Clayton J
Kendall L Joel S and Meredith I
uh I don't know what I would do I I
couldn't do it I love you guys thank you
for listening to the podcast thanks for
supporting us Ryan from the Hollywood
Hills in California I am Michael Rose
Michael Rosenbaum and I am Brian Taylor
a little wave to the camera we love you
guys thanks for continuing to join us uh
be good to yourselves
foreign